happy Columbus Day everybody and
congratulations to anybody out there who
actually gets to take off on Columbus
Day I think that's a group that's now
limited to like public school teachers
and post office employees I don't know
if anyone else gets off anymore for
Columbus Day but it is it is a day to
remember a great man and yes I say a
great man Christopher Columbus was a
great man why was he great well because
he he sailed across uncharted waters to
an unknown destination and he then and
then he did it three more times and in
the process he vastly expanded our
knowledge and understanding of the world
he planted the seeds of Western
civilization
he changed the globe he changed the
course of history had an impact on
civilization that has lasted for five
hundred years and will last for 500 more
in a thousand years after that I would
say that's something isn't it that's
kind of impressive
maybe worthy of a statue may be worthy
of your own day now if you want to have
your own day in the future you want to
have your own statue then do the same
thing change the course of history go
ahead and try if it's so easy to do one
thing I'll say about Columbus City he
certainly had an impact on history that
far exceeds the impact that his
ungrateful modern critics who enjoy the
bounty of Western civilization while
whining about the men who provided that
bounty to them will have because those
people who sit on Twitter and complain
and say Christopher Columbus he was a he
was a genocide Ulm Aynak those people
are gonna die and be forgotten nobody's
gonna remember them because they're not
doing anything with their lives
Christopher Columbus has remembered 500
years later all I'm gonna say is this is
that if if and hopefully maybe we can at
least agree on this score if you can't
even drive to the neighboring state I
forget about that if you can't even
drive to your neighboring town if you
can't even drive to your local grocery
store without the help of a satellite
orbiting the Earth giving you
step-by-step instructions
Tsang turn left here turn right there go
1.2 miles turn right okay if you can't
even do that if you can't even get to
your CBS 5 blocks away without having to
call upon the satellite satellite help
me then maybe you can at least admit
that it's kind of impressive that
Columbus and his crew managed to make a
voyage across thousands of miles of open
ocean and then make it to a certain area
on the map that wasn't even on the map
yet because the map hadn't been drawn
yet and then make it back there three
more times using routes by the way that
are still used today five hundred years
later oh but he thought he was going to
Asia stupid Columbus Shh Shh thought he
was going to age I didn't know where he
was going yes it's true that Columbus
committed the sin of not already having
a completed map in front of him do you
know why you have a completed map well
in fact if you had a completed map you
couldn't use it yeah because these days
even with even with a map even if
someone gives us a map we are so
ineffectual that even if someone gives
us a map and shows us where to go we
couldn't do it we can't even read a map
if you live in in Cincinnati Ohio and I
gave you a map to show you how to get to
Lexington Kentucky if you're like a
modern American you you couldn't even do
it you wouldn't have any idea what's
this line mean what is that no you need
the satellite to say listen dummy make a
right here left there okay go one that's
what you need but Columbus he didn't
have the satellite he didn't have a map
either and the reason he named a map is
because because no one had made a map of
the world yet and the reason no one had
made a map of the world is that no one
had seen the entire world okay there
were large swaths of the planet that
nobody had seen and so how could he know
oh but the Vikings found North America
they Viking
yeah the Vikings did find North America
but they didn't they didn't establish
lasting settlements they didn't they
didn't build upon that discovery and
that's how nobody knew the Vikings
didn't understand what they had
discovered but yeah Leif Eriksson I mean
give the Vikings credit - I give all
these guys credit it's very impressive
to get into a ship having no idea really
where you're going and to just sail that
way that's how they that's how the map
was originally drawn is that someone had
to get in a ship and just go that away
and just like hundreds of years later
when they went when when when it was
time to make a you know a comprehensive
map of the continental United States
someone had to just go that away across
the entire expanse of the continental US
I mean this took there had to be
courageous pioneering men to do this and
I am grateful that they did yeah these
guys they weren't perfect in in some
ways they had to not be perfect because
do you have any idea what it would what
it'd work what kind of person you have
to be to get on a ship leading a fleet
of ships with a bunch of men and go
across unknown waters you have no idea
how long you're gonna be going or how
far you're gonna have to go you have no
idea if you're gonna survive there's a
very good chance you won't there's a
very good chance you'll die but to
maintain order and discipline and to
prevent you know mutiny and to prevent
them from throwing you overboard when
they get tired sick and tired of being
on the ship and to make sure that
everyone doesn't starve to death or die
of scurvy do you know what's required it
takes men who are yes a little bit
brutal a little bit uh dictatorial even
that's what was required we
out that without those kinds of men
doing those things Western civilization
as we know it does not exist and I for
one am quite glad that it does exist
because I like living here it's not
perfect there are problems I'll be the
first to point out those problems and
criticize those problems but but I
prefer living in Western civilization
than anywhere else and here's what I'll
say to you if you if you feel terrible
about living here if you feel like if
you feel guilt ridden we have no right
to be here we stole this land we're on
stolen land so on and so forth well if
you really feel that way then you are
welcome to leave and I don't I don't
mean that as you know this is not if you
don't like it get out that's not exactly
what this is well that's a little bit
what this is but it's true that that
it's not even if you don't like it it's
more if you feel like there's a real
moral problem with us even being here
then I think you are morally obligated
to leave if you really feel like this is
stolen property then why are you staying
here go somewhere else
I hear the Middle East is very nice this
time of year of course the problem is if
you go anywhere else on the globe
especially in the Middle East but really
anywhere you are inevitably going to end
up on quote/unquote stolen land because
no matter where you go unless you're
going to in our Antarctica or something
okay unless you're going to someplace
where nobody lives if you're going to a
place where there are people you are
more than likely going to end up not
matter where it is no matter what
content doesn't matter you're gonna end
up in a place that has been
quote/unquote stolen historically
probably multiple times the people
living on that plot of land their
ancestors probably stole it from the
people who were living before and those
people were probably stole it from the
people before that because for thousands
of years of human civilization that's
the way the world worked it was a time
of conquest where if you wanted to live
on a certain plot of land you fought for
it and that's
way at work everywhere it's not pretty
it's not nice but that's the way it
worked and it's very easy for us in the
year 2019 to sit here and say well that
that that feels wrong I don't like that
that makes me that makes my tummy hurt
to think that people did that I don't
like it okay well you know that's what
your ancestors did that's what
everybody's ancestors did I mean coming
to coming to the new world it what do
you think the Indian civilizations were
doing you think they were just living
peacefully with each other just playing
patty-cake what do you think they were
doing how do you think the Aztecs when
when when Cortes came across the Aztec
civilization what is now Mexico how do
you think they got all that land they
were living on how do you think they got
it you think they just they just came in
and asked that try the the inhabiting
tribes nicely hey would you guys mind if
we set up a civilization here would you
mind oh you would well never mind see
you later
no you know what they did they came in
they killed almost everybody and of the
survivors they would take some of the
children and some of the women and some
of someone when they take a sex slaves
and some of the children they would take
and they would cut out their hearts as
human sacrifices and then cut off their
limbs and eat them so the Aztecs did
that's how they gained land it was a
brutal time very brutal and nobody's
ancestral hands are clean nobody but
again if you feel bad about it if you're
if you're real torn up I would I would
respect that you know I would respect
someone who says you know what I just I
really feel this is stolen land and I'm
going to give my land back you could
call up a you know a an Indian
Reservation you could say hey you know
I've got property I want to donate it to
you and I'm gonna go live and I don't
know where I don't know where you're
gonna go like I said there's nowhere you
can really go that isn't stolen but you
could find something maybe you will go
down Antarctica they have reefs
facilities down there you could see if
you could set up shop in one of those
build an Engel a glue or something maybe
so that was my yearly annual Columbus
rant and now a word from Rock auto
the thing about the chain stores that
you go to for Auto Parts is that they
have all kinds of little tricks they
pull to get more money out of you and
one is that they'll have different price
tiers depending on if you're a
professional or not well Rock Auto they
don't do that they don't mess around
with any of that rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than charging based on what they think
they can get out of you right
rockauto.com is for everybody and if you
don't need a count login you don't need
a membership or anything like that you
just go there you find what you need
here's what I really like about Rock
Auto they're a family business they've
been doing this a long time they get the
family business so you feel like you can
trust them but just because it's a
family operation that doesn't mean that
they've sacrificed anything in terms of
selection they they've still got
everything you need from engine control
modules brake parts to tell lamps motor
oil even new carpet if that's what you
need you can find it at Rock Auto
whether it's for your classic or your
daily driver get everything you need in
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door you're not gonna get it
cheaper not gonna get it easier than you
will with rockauto.com amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts of
your car that you're ever gonna need
it's all there rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
walsh into their how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you
again that's rockauto.com okay um let's
see what's the controversy of the day
well Columbus what Columbus is won
controversy because 500 years later of
course people still haven't quite gotten
over things but the other controversy is
over this meme and I could hardly say
that with without laughing because of
course a controversy over a meme is just
really that's a that's that's very
worthwhile isn't it for us to have a
controversy over a meme there was an
event for Trump supporters a few days
ago hosted by a group called American
priority and it was held at a Trump
resort
in Miami apparently during this event
from what I've heard in one of the side
rooms at the resort there was a session
about means and I don't really know why
but there was and a bunch of memes were
being played and one of the memes has
people very upset today because it shows
President Trump murdering a bunch of
news media logos and a few people - not
real people but the faces of people
transplanted on other people and I'm not
sure how much of this they'll let me
play but I wanted to give you a quick
sampling of this of this controversial
mean that has people very upset today so
here's a here's a little bit of that
watch how dare you separate them from
their parents we're gonna work his son
from his mother sauce and throw a cake
[Music]
[Music]
so the video as I said it shows Trump
and what looks like a church shooting a
bunch of media logos and media people
from the reports I've read this was
played in as I said a side room most of
the attendees didn't see it who weren't
aware of it they learned about it in the
media reports Trump himself obviously
had nothing to do with this he didn't he
didn't put it together his campaign had
nothing to do with it someone someone
played it in a mostly empty room a few
people saw it and now everyone has seen
it because the media ironically has
amplified this message a message that
they think is so dangerous and horrible
yet they're the ones putting it out
there for everybody to see now it is in
poor taste certainly it's important it's
stupid it's stupid on a number of level
levels and it's even dumber for a
supporter to play something like that at
an extensible Trump event because who do
you think you're helping like what good
do you think is gonna come of that so
whoever it is that put that together and
then decided to play at a trouble that
is it you're definitely not helping the
guy that you're ostensibly trying to
support there is no universe where
that's helpful best-case scenario is
that it makes a few Trump supporters
laugh but that's it's not you're not
gonna win any any votes and win or win
any favor that way so it's a very stupid
thing but I can't help but think you
know this meme uses what is obviously a
scene from a movie and it turns out that
the movie is called Kingsman a movie a
well-known blockbuster movie and now
it's a franchise how many how many
Kingsman movies it's a bit up in two or
three Kingsman movies now I haven't seen
them but apparently there's a scene in
that film where a guy Colin Firth
slaughters a bunch of people at a church
and apparently in the original movie the
these are Westboro Baptist Church type
people so basically it's a parody of
what Hollywood thinks you know all
churches are like this is a parody of
the quarter
Hollywood every Church especially in the
south and the protagonist colin firth
murders almost everybody in the building
in the original scene and I do have to
wonder if this meme is so offensive and
so potentially dangerous and in such
poor taste why doesn't the original
scene also offensive and dangerous and
in poor taste so if a guy is
slaughtering a bunch of media members
it's a problem but if you law if he
slaughters a bunch of rubes at a church
it's okay that message is fine this
scene has been out there for almost five
years now nobody ever complained about
it in fact in fact it's more than that
it's not just that nobody complained
about this scene when it first came out
it's that they actively celebrated it
let me let me read a relevant passage
from a 2015 Washington Post review of
Kingsman this is what this is what the
Washington Post in 2015 had to say about
that scene when it was just Christians
getting murdered and not media members
they said of course this being a modern
movie there's loads of violence though
most of it is bloodless and surprisingly
melenik Hellenic ballet you know like a
ballet is well they say it's like a
ballet one Massacre set in a
conservative Christian Church in the
American deep south is a master class in
cartoonish fight choreography a master
class now I was trying to find out more
about the context of this original scene
and I found an article on the wringer
calm from a few years ago which says
that this scene of Colin Firth
slaughtering churchgoers is the most
quote well-regarded scene in the movie
and and then the article goes on to use
a lot of very glowing language to talk
about it the article says quote it's an
unquestionably brilliant kinetic scene 1
that without doubt is a masterclass in
fight timing and filming masterclass
this was the favorite phrase apparently
used to describe the scene so again when
it's a a British guy
shooting a bunch of parodies of
Christians
it's a masterclass it's ballet it's
kinetic it's it's enthralling it's it's
it's it's beautiful to watch but when
it's a meme of Trump shooting a bunch of
media people now it's horrible to
disgrace it's violent it's it's it's
dangerous all of these things now the
fact that these characters who are being
killed in the original scene and not
even characters they're just meat
puppets whose only function is just to
get shot in the head but the fact that
they're supposed to be Westboro Baptist
types just makes it worse in some ways
because one that's how Hollywood again
sees all Christians especially in the
south
but to making them Westboro Baptist
people is just a cheap narrative trick
which allows the viewer to find sick joy
in watching Christians get killed you
just make that one little you know make
them racists and all of a sudden we can
all watch it and enjoy it when in
reality of course yes the Westboro
Baptists people are scumbags I think we
could all agree though that it wouldn't
be OK to go and shoot 50 of them in the
head right but this allows people
especially media elites they can watch a
scene like that and play out their sick
fantasies of killing Christians and they
could feel okay about it because the
Christians in this movie are racist
never mind that again that the media
thinks that all Christians are racist so
as far as they're concerned those could
be anybody any Christian and I mean I
don't know how else to interpret it
because if you're someone who saw the
original scene and you loved it and then
you see this meme and you say this is
terrible because it is it allows people
to fantasize about killing media members
well then I can only say okay well so
that's how you see it so well then why
did you love it before I could only
assume it's because you it allowed you
to fantasize about killing Christians
but if you're gonna say that oh no the
original scene is just a cartoon it's a
joke it's not you know it's it's it's
it's nothing there's nothing to it it's
don't worry about it if you're gonna say
that about the original scene then how
do you not say that about the mean
couldn't the same excuse be made for the
mean couldn't anyone say well it's just
a joke it's not anything serious no
one's taking it seriously seems to me
you need to have a consistent narrative
a consistent a consistent approach all
right so let's see what else here this
was fun look at this headline from
Forbes the headline says why Pakistan
should be on every solo female travelers
bucket list
why Pakistan should be on every solo
female travelers bucket list I'm just
waiting for the follow-up of this like
why a back alley in West Baltimore is a
great place for any solo female or
female to go camping or maybe why the
shark tank at the aquarium is a great
place to bathe your toddler or maybe why
the microwave is a great place to stick
your head just wonderful advice from the
media as always and and the media is so
desperate to be woke that they're gonna
encourage a bunch of women to go out and
get kidnapped or imprisoned or murdered
just to prove how woke they are so
that's that's that's wonderful
now this was kind of interesting I want
to play this for you really quick here's
Bernie Sanders in an interview trying to
differentiate himself from Elizabeth
Warren Elizabeth Warren is but a friend
of mine for some 25 years and I think
she is a very very good senator but
there are differences between Elizabeth
and myself Elizabeth I think as you know
has said that she is a capitalist
through her bones I'm not I think the
situation today that we face in this
country of the greed and the corruption
that it's existing in Washington that is
existing at the corporate elite level
where you have massive amounts of
price-fixing going on in the drug
companies where we're the only major
country on earth not the guarantee
healthcare to all people where we have
right now as we speak in the fossil fuel
industry you've got companies making
billions of dollars a year in profit
doing
what oh by the way they're destroying
the planet alright and I think business
as usual and doing it the old-fashioned
way it's not good enough it's not
regulation now what we need is in fact I
don't want to get people to nervous we
need a political revolution I am I
believe the only candidate who's going
to say to the ruling class of this
country the corporate elite enough
enough with your greed and with your
corruption we need real change in this
country so you don't think that's what
Elizabeth Warren well look Lizabeth it's
a friend of mine she will speak for
herself but you have said there are
differences a difference is a label I
guess well it's not a label I mean
Lizabeth considers herself if I got the
quote correctly to be a capitalist to
her bones I don't and the reason I am
NOT is because I will not tolerate for
one second the kind of greed and
corruption and income and wealth
inequality and so much suffering that is
going on in this country today which is
unnecessary
I love how on the Left these days you
can you can accuse your opponent of
supporting freedom too much that's
basically the accusation right well you
know the difference between me and her
is that is that is that she still sort
of believes in Liberty a little bit
that's her problem now it used to be
that the left gave lip service to
freedom they they supported and enjoyed
and loved freedom in theory but not in
practice now they've kind of dropped
they've torn off the masks they've
dropped the act and they don't even
support freedom in theory anymore
they're just anti freedom and that's
that's Bernie Sanders that's his whole
campaign really that's his whole
campaign is saying you know you don't
need freedom and liberty cares about
that what you need is the government to
take care of you my children that's what
you need their their pat on the head ok
one other thing before we get the emails
Media Matters you know I I love Media
Matters at the deal here at the Daily
wire we all love Media Matters they do
so much to promote us and for free you
know all these companies are stuck sort
of paying for marketing well we have
Media Matters to market for us for free
and my favorite things in Media Matters
does is uh they'll watch all the daily
wire shows they're watching this one
right now so thank you are watching
whatever Media Matters minion is
watching I say hello and thank you for
being here welcome to the show
hope you found something useful what I
would recommend actually Media Matters
guy is go I'm sure you probably already
done it but my opening thing about
Columbus I'm sure there's stuff you
could find there maybe maybe cut a clip
of that put it on accuse me of racism or
whatever whatever you're gonna do
xenophobia whatever your thing is who
knows maybe even homophobia maybe
there's the way you can make that
homophobic I don't know it's always fun
to see what you guys do with it I really
enjoy it because I enjoy I do the show
and you know I make my points and then I
love to see how the media matters they
can take something that I've said and
find a point that I didn't make and I
just I love to see how they do it kind
of putting the pieces of the puzzle
together so I'll look forward to that
because I know what my show is about but
then I go to Media Matters and I find
out what they think it was about so I
can go and say well what was my show
about today anyway um they so last week
they were going after Ben because he had
the audacity to say that he would
physically defend his child against
forced and docked indoctrination by the
state a sentiment shared by literally
any loving parent in the country you
know what he said about that that he
would physically defend his child from
from from forced to doctrine ation
that's any parent would feel that way
now they also came after me and I
thought this was great Jason Campbell at
Media Matters posted this clip of my
show from Friday he posted it because he
thought it was really bad and
controversial and outrageous and he
thought people will be mad at me about
it and let me let me play I hope this
isn't too self-indulgent but I want to
play for you the clip of my show that
Jason Campbell for Media Matters put up
watch this it's almost like these
parents are conditioning their kids to
have gender confusion so that they the
parents can parade their
like fashion statements saying look at
me look how woke I am my own kid is
transgender look look it's horrifying it
really is that young girl and and she is
a girl she is being abused this is
psychological and emotional abuse of the
worst kind because you're depriving her
of a childhood you're depriving her of
an identity you are forcing her to have
an identity crisis I just love that
because and if you go and you if you go
to Twitter and you see that that post
from from Jason Campbell you're gonna
find you reading you look at the
comments most of the comments are saying
well yeah I agree with them absolutely
because what I'm saying there is just
it's it's not any great insight there's
nothing there's nothing terribly
insightful or
smart about it it's just it's just
really basic common sense that any sane
normal person agrees with that trying to
impose gender confusion on your child is
abusive it is psychological and
emotional abuse i 100% stand by that i
make absolutely no apology for it at all
i'll just continue to reiterate the
point and and what's more this is again
any normal person agrees so you find how
the left is just they're getting to the
point now where they don't even
understand how normal people think where
they see a clip like that and they think
so here's the great thing is that media
matters they didn't even try to twist it
or usually they'll twist what what one
of us says and they'll try to like I
said they'll try to find racism or
homophobia or whatever where it doesn't
exist but in this case they thought that
what I said was so self-evidently
terrible that they didn't even have to
explain it they would just quote it put
the clip up
context I'll admit that's totally in
context and they thought it's just
self-explanatory put it up and people
would see it and think how horrible that
man is when really it's the opposite 90%
of people hear that and think yeah of
course that's how I feel they they're
going so far off the cliff that they
they're not even capable of
understanding how normal people think it
is it's remarkable and now we've gotten
to the point now on the Left where you
know having a child who seven-year-old
transgender child that on the left now
is this mainstream thing where
everyone's supposed to accept it nobody
can question it when of course 10 years
ago even people on the Left would have
said well hold on a second this is
that's hold on I mean they're kids let's
let's let's calm down for a second here
so you're taking this position that 10
years ago even on the far left would
have seemed radical kind of absurd way
too far and now it's mainstream and if
you question it then you are self
evidently a bigot in their mind all
right let's go to emails Matt well show
at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com this is from Jessica says hi
I'm Adam big fan of your show I listen
to it every day while I'm at work
I heard about a joke that SNL made about
Pope Francis saying that there were
going to be discussions about lifting
the celibacy requirement for priests I
looked up the article and I believe it
was in response to a specific situation
in parts of South Africa where the
church or South America rather where the
church is under represented as a
Catholic I've often wondered if allowing
priests to be married and have families
would be such a big deal I feel like
since there's a priest shortage in
general not just in South America that
allowing them to be married and have
families would make priesthood a more
realistic option for people and more men
would be interested in becoming one yeah
Jessica I find myself more and more
amenable to this idea I think the desire
to have a family to have a wife is a
good and healthy desire for a man to
have the church is ruling out
a lot of potentially good priests simply
because they have a good and healthy
desire and I think maybe that's not a
good strategy I think to remain celibate
your whole life requires a superhuman
self-control and it's obvious that a lot
of priests don't have that self-control
but they're being set up to fail you
know they're being set up to fail in
service of an extraordinary requirement
that in and of itself is not really
necessary and maybe not even beneficial
so you're setting up all these priests
to fail simply because they can't manage
to what reject the very natural desire
to have a family and that is what and
that's what a lot of people don't
understand and in the church the
problems in the priesthood you know when
we talk about this now when we're
talking about the the pedophilia in the
priesthood well with that getting rid of
the celibacy requirement that's not
going to do anything for that
if you've got pedophiles coming in the
priesthood that's you know whatever the
celibacy requirement is that's saying
you're not going to solve that the
pedophile problem
and people always point that out they
say well that's you know so the celibacy
requirement isn't like nothing to do
with it it's not gonna solve the problem
yeah it's not gonna solve that issue but
that's been the minority of cases the
the more common and more widespread
problem even if doesn't get media
attention because the media doesn't
really care about it but if you talk to
any priest they'll tell you that the
more widespread issue is just priests
who end up in consensual relationships
with other adults men or women and that
is a big issue in priesthood across the
board man it probably always has been to
a certain extent because again when
you're when you're telling people that
they have to be celibate their whole
lives there's going to be a certain
probably significant percentage who just
can't do it
they can't live up to that but I
wonder if this is if this is creating a
lot of chaos and turmoil and everything
that isn't necessary and so maybe the
maybe the church could say yeah if
you're a married man faithful to your
wife you have a family
sure we welcome you maybe that's exactly
the kind of man we want in the
priesthood it turns out all right um
let's go to from Nathan says Matt what
did you think of the new Breaking Bad
movie yeah El Camino the Breaking Bad
movie came out I know a lot of people
were disappointed in it came out on
Netflix on Friday I really liked it I
thought it was a very good epilogue to
Breaking Bad series it didn't reinvent
the wheel but it wasn't supposed to I I
enjoyed going back and revisiting those
characters I think Vince Gilligan is a
genius the writer of the show creator of
the show to be able to go back after
what five or six years and reclaim you
know kind of not just tell that not just
go back into that world but really
capture that world again I think a lot
of people couldn't do that and you see
so often where you have these shows that
are resurrected or whatever after many
years and they fail to capture the feel
of the original show and in this case I
think I think Gilligan did a great job
of that and so I liked it all right this
is from Mitchell says hi Matt love the
show and seeing as though you're a new
father once more I'm wondering what your
thoughts are on spanking your children
I'm 25 and not thinking of having a
child yet however I am torn on this
topic and hope that you can shed some
insight yeah Mitchell it's a great
question so there are two to sort of
different questions here one is am i
against spanking in principle and the
second is do I do I myself choose to
spank my kids the answer to the second
one is no I don't we don't spank but
that doesn't necessarily mean that our
answer to the first question is yes that
we're against it in principle okay so so
this is really our thought process my
well my wife and I are on the same page
but I'm not gonna speak for her so I'll
just speak for myself this is my thought
process
I don't spank our kids and I'll tell you
the reason I think that spanking can be
a valid legitimate constructive form of
discipline I also think it can be abuse
right and I think we'd all agree right
that that I mean nobody thinks no decent
person thinks that parents just have
carte blanche to hit their kids whenever
they want however they want for whatever
reason in whatever way obviously there
is such a thing as physical abuse no I
don't think that spanking in principle
is physical abuse but I think it can be
and I think the line between
constructive discipline and abuse is is
somewhat subtle and that scares me
because again on one side of that line
is constructive discipline on the other
sign is well you're physically abusing
your kid and so you know it's a it's a
it can be a somewhat fine line sometimes
but the fact that on one side of that
line is something so horrific like
physical abuse of a child that that you
know it scares me a little bit so here's
what I think it comes down to if you're
hitting your child in anger call it
spanking if you want but if you're if
you are spanking your child because
you're pissed off and and you're you
know you had a long day you're
overwhelmed you're at the end of your
rope whatever that is physical abuse no
question now there's nothing wrong with
being angry and and being frustrated you
had a long day you're at the end you're
up maybe all parents feel like that
sometimes I know that I do but hitting
your child as a way of communicating
your frustration or letting off steam is
physical abuse obviously there's no way
around it my concern my worry is that I
think a lot of people who spank their
kids spanked them like that in anger
that's even the
spanking and this is not necessarily a
fair sample but the kind of spanking
that you see in public sometimes where a
mother is you know kind of losing your
temper at the grocery store and swatting
the kid or whatever we've all seen
scenes like that that's almost always in
anger now it's not necessarily a it's
not a fair sampling because the people
who are who don't spank and anger are by
definition not doing it in public so we
don't really see that happening but you
know I often hear people reminiscing
about fondly about their own physical
abuse as a kid it's sort of disturbing
and what it tells me is that they're
probably doing the same thing to their
kids if they have such a fun if they if
they think of it in such a in such a
positive way what happened to them but
you know you'll hear people it's like
when there's a there's a story about a
kid behaving terribly at school and
you'll hear someone say something like
oh man you know when I was a kid
if I did that when I got home my dad
would would have lost it and beat the
hell out of me okay so your dad would
have abused you is what you're saying
your dad would have gotten angry and
taken out his frustration by beating up
a child so you realize that's bad right
you know you realize that you your dad
abused you that's abuse it's not okay
it's to beat up a child because you're
pissed off is cowardly and wrong and
it's just it's that's not okay so maybe
it's just a figure of speech or
something but the way people sometimes
talk about the discipline that they got
when they were kids hearing the story I
think as a parent that is actually
horrible I would never do that to my kid
now I mean even a phrase like and you
hear this like beat the hell out oh my
dad would a beat the hell out beat the
hell out of you that's again that's not
no that's that's not good that was your
dad being a coward if that's really what
he did I mean what beat the hell out of
a seven-year-old and it is it's a and
you're putting that that's what that's
that's um
manly form of being a parent I mean
control your emotions be a man control
yourself
that's what you want from your own kids
where we tell our own kids all the time
use your words control yourself it's not
okay to get mad and hit somebody I'm
telling my own my own six-year-old son
this all the time because he's a child
and he has a lot of aggression he
doesn't know how to communicate it and
so he'll get man you'll hit somebody and
so I'm always telling him that's not
okay you do not express your anger that
way so how can I turn around and do it
if I'm telling him all the time not to
do it now on the other hand not all
spanking is like that I think there is a
healthy form of it the healthy form is
one completely devoid of anger I think
this is so important there is no anger
in it at all you're spanking your child
because that is the penalty and you're
taking a very businesslike approach and
you're saying okay here's what you did
here's the penalty and now I'm going to
dole out that penalty you're not angry
you're not beating the hell out of
you're not anything like that it's just
you are you are giving the child the
penalty and you are in control of your
emotions the whole time I think that
kind of spanking is fine and that is
that that's fine parenting that's good
parenting and I know that there are
parents who spank that way and and I say
about that that that you know great I we
don't do it in our family because it's
not right for us I don't think but I
think that if that's what you do fine
but I just you know I think it's so
important to emphasize that there cannot
be any emotion or anger in it
and but that's the
is that we we naturally get angry at our
kids and parenting it can be a very
emotional thing a lot of the time not
just because you're angry at your kid
but because you're you love your kid
your there's a lot of frustration you
just you want your you know you just
parent thing is just a jumble of
emotions sometimes and it's hard to sort
through it so I don't know
to put those emotions totally to the
side and administer a punishment like
that like as I said we just don't do it
but you can that be difficult sometimes
I don't know I just it worries me that
again the way people talk about spanking
often the way they talk about the way
they describe it either their own
experience of it when they were kids or
how they dole it out now as parents from
the way it sounds it sounds an awful lot
like abuse and that that concerns me so
that's what I would say alright we'll
leave it there thanks everybody for
watching thanks for listening Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you